Hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel. Uh I've got to do a pretty
quick one today uh because I'm going to
run into work in a second, but uh you
may notice that my mustache is missing,
which is tragic because as we all know,
it looked extremely sick and cool and uh
I've been forced to shave it by the
forces that be. Um but yeah, just going
to have to go ahead and uh move on with
life and stay strong. So let's get into
this video. Today we'll be building out
Uber's location index. As a recap from
the last video, Uber uses their location
index to match riders with nearby
drivers. Drivers are constantly updating
their location in the index so that when
passengers create a ride request, Uber
servers can very efficiently figure out
a set of drivers to notify. Let's
formalize the APIs that the Uber
location service needs to satisfy.
First, drivers should be able to update
their location in the index. They can do
this by calling the ping endpoint. Next,
riders should be able to quickly compute
the set of nearest drivers within a
distance threshold. This distance
threshold is configurable. As we
discussed in the last video, let's
estimate that across our index, we'll
receive a million location updates per
second from each driver. My sources
online tell me that Uber coordinates
over 30 million trips daily. If we
convert that to a per second metric and
assume a uniform distribution, we'll
also be servicing 350 queries per second
to find all the nearest drivers for our
rider. The number of driver pings in
particular here is quite large. As we
discussed in the last video, we need to
place each one in a geospatial index.
This allows us to efficiently compute
all drivers within a distance of a
target point. I'm not sure whether there
are any databases that can handle a
million index writes per second,
especially when you toss some reads in
there, too. Ultimately, we need a way of
scaling the system out across many
nodes. There are a bunch of different
ways of sharding out a database, all
with their own trade-offs. In the
following approaches that we'll discuss,
we'll roundroin driver pings to each
shard to maintain an even load on each
server. That sounds pretty promising on
paper, not much unlike my ex-girlfriend.
Let's see what happens in practice,
though. Let's imagine that when a rider
wants to find the closest drivers, they
pick a random shard and look at who is
closest to them. As we can see in the
diagram, we may end up matching our
rider with a non-optimal driver. To
mitigate this, our rider could instead
read from all shards and aggregate the
results. In this situation, our query is
going to be bottlenecked by the latency
of the slowest shard. When thinking
about how to shard out a database, we
want to consider our querying patterns.
If possible, the best way to establish
partitions is to do so in a way that we
only have to interact with a single
shard at a time. In our case, we only
care about having to be able to find all
points within a certain distance of some
potential passenger. Implicitly, that
means that we want all drivers that are
close proximity to one another to live
on the same partition. This is going to
be our guiding approach. Let's introduce
a new technology out of Uber, which is
called H3. H3 maps out the entire globe
into a bunch of fixed size hexagons and
some pentagons. and in many ways
resembles a quad tree except each cell
has seven children instead of four. H3
is really useful for performing
bucketing of geographic locations which
is exactly what we want to be doing
here. Each one of these hexagons has a
unique cell ID. In order to get the cell
ID for a given point, H3 provides really
easy to use utilities. All you need to
provide is a latitude and longitude and
something known as a resolution, which
we'll explain now. As we saw in our last
picture, a driver's location can
actually be contained in many different
cells. This is because bigger cells,
which are known as lower resolution,
actually contain smaller cells at higher
resolution. H3 has preset areas for all
cells of a given resolution, which I've
attached on screen.
This is pretty great, right? We can just
pick a resolution that we think is good
enough for us, get the H3 cell for a
latitude and a longitude, and use that
as our shard key. We don't want to pick
one that's too small since otherwise
we're going to have a ton of partitions
which is lots of extra overhead on our
systems. Let's say that we choose
resolution 2 giving us 6,000 clean
shards of 90,000 km. This seems really
good at first but could break down in
practice. Those zones are pretty big and
we know that in reality Uber has hot
spots. For example, Uber is probably
serving a lot more rides in New York,
London, and Paris than they do in
Topeka, Kansas. While we still want to
use the cell ID as our partition key, in
some places we may want to use a cell
key at a higher resolution. For example,
in the eastern United States, we may
want to use resolution 6, which is 36 km
per shard. How can we accomplish this?
When a driver sends their latitude and
longitude to a server, the server needs
to figure out the resolution they should
use for the H3 cell. In order to do
this, we can publish a mapping of all
the H3 cells that form distinct
partitions. We can just keep a Postgress
table known as H3 shards which lists all
the cell ids. If a system administrator
notices that one particular shard is
experiencing a lot of load, they can
remove the H3 shard from this table and
atomically add entries for all seven of
the children. This way any subsequent
pings in the cell will be distributed
across the child cells which should live
on different physical nodes. When a
driver or a rider needs to figure out
what H3 cell ID it should use, it can
start by computing the largest H3 cell
that it's a member of. If that's one of
our partitions, then great. We can stop
there and just use it. Otherwise, we
should compute the H3 cell at the next
resolution until we find one in the H3
shard index. Then we can employ the
shard to figure out where to route the
query to at a million pings per second.
I'm going to be super conservative and
say we'll never need more than 100,000
shards. Rather than having to load all
of the H3 partition keys from the
database all the time, we can cache this
in a hash set on each server. Every
minute or so, the servers can pull that
database in order to refresh the list in
the background. As a result of this
caching, one situation that could happen
here is that servers may route a driver
ping to the wrong shard. If a partition
is split into many, there's a short
period of time where a location ping may
be sent to its old shard. At the end of
the day, this isn't a big deal. Recall
that for each driver ping, we
automatically expire it after a few
seconds. This means that any rows that
are created on the wrong shard will just
go away. And after a bit longer, our
server will get an updated list of valid
H3 cells that we can use as our sharding
keys. When it comes to servicing
passenger requests for rides, we want
proximity queries to go to the right
place. In that case, we can actually
read from the database instead of our
local cache. These aren't nearly as
frequent though, so it's really not a
big deal. Let's bring together the
highle design. We'll start by just
establishing the infrastructure here.
Our main location index is a postgress
table using the postgis extension. This
allows us to maintain a geospatial index
per shard which is exactly what we need
here. We can use situs to scale this out
over a large cluster of Postgress nodes
and use the H3 cell ID column as our
partition key. Hash range partitioning
over this column should be good enough
here. We'll also have a table to list
our current valid H3 buckets.
administrators can come along and change
the list to either split a cell into its
children or take a bunch of child cells
and replace them with their parent to
change how our tables are partitioned.
When it comes to handling pings from a
driver, the first thing that we can do
is get our H3 cell ID for the latitude
and longitude at resolution zero. If
that's in the H3 shard table, that's
great. If not, we keep traversing down
until we find a cell ID that is. Keep in
mind that ideally the entries in the
shard table are already cached on our
server to minimize the number of network
calls to make here. We then upload a row
to our Postgress table with the
appropriate H3 cell ID, geohash, and
driver ID and Citus takes care of
routing it to the proper shard for us.
When finding nearby drivers for our ride
request, the first thing that we need to
do is figure out the shard key for the
rider's latitude and longitude in the
same way that we did for our driver.
However, this step is a little bit more
complex. If I'm a rider and I'm right on
the edge of my H3 shard boundary, I
won't consider any drivers that are
right across that edge. This means that
we'd potentially find a sub-optimal
driver. Recall that we're searching for
all drivers within a distance of x miles
to a rider. We can basically outline the
circle on the map. We can figure out a
few latitude and longitude points on the
edge of that circle. For example, x
miles north, south, east, and west. This
is really doable with basic math. From
there, we can figure out the shards that
all of those points belong to. The
majority of the time, they should be the
same as our writers location, but some
of the points may require checking other
cells. Finally, we issue a query to the
appropriate shards in our location
index, which utilize the local
geospatial index per shard. Since we
specify which H3 shards were searching
in our query, Citus will route it to
only the appropriate nodes as opposed to
all of them. In this video, I mainly
used H3 because it abstracts away from
any difficulty with trying to bucket
similar locations to one another. That
being said, some of you may recall from
prior videos that geohash values that
are in close proximity to one another
are actually lexographically similar.
What this means is that we could also
range partition our geospatial index by
geohash range. While this works nicely
in theory, in practice it becomes a
little bit tough to actually deal with.
we'd have to be careful to manually
reconfigure our ranges for every single
shard as opposed to our existing
solution which is basically just split
the big shard and evenly redistribute
its children to other nodes in the
cluster. Thanks everyone for stopping
by. I hope you enjoyed the video. Uh I
think this is a cool one to actually
discuss geos sharding a little bit. Uh
in the next one I think we'll talk about
sharding out a search index since I
didn't really talk about that too much
for the sake of the Yelp video. And uh
yeah, looking forward to it. See y'all
soon.